hello everyone and welcome back to the
match that keeps on giving uh it's
magnus carlsen versus radoslav
yesterday we've seen a game between the
two of them it was a really crazy one
and they didn't draw but now
this one uh well anything can happen so
let's just get uh
straight into it now magnus with the
white pieces uh he will of course uh try
to try and win it and win it in the
classical
uh watash will also try to do the same
and if not we are going into tie breaks
so let's see what happened here and this
game
really really a crazy one that features
a moment uh
that is not easily explained as you'll
see so magnus with the white pieces
opens with
e4 we have c5 by radica going for the
sicilian defense knight f3 d6 and now
bishop to b5
check there's the bishop to b5 check
going for the canal attack or
i always miss if it's the the rosso limo
or the rosalina
medina or there are many names to this
to this move
so knight to d7 and now d4
now we have c capture sunday for knight
captures on d4
and now knight to f6 we have castles uh
this is all very standard stuff we have
a6 attacking the bishop
and now there is one game where bishop
captures and b7 was played but here we
have bishop to a4
and it is now already as of move seven
that we have a completely new game so
let's see
how radical continues here we have e6
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop castle that came to safety
and just continued development and now
c4 a very principled idea from white and
this is something that you can always
choose to do if black allows you to play
this
c4 move if there's nothing hanging in in
the center
then you could always play it it keeps a
nice eye here on the b5 square also you
gain uh extreme control of the center
here
and while knight captures on e4 is
possible now obviously magnus has
something prepared for this for example
knight captures rook to a1 there will be
a lot of pressure here on the e6 square
for example if the knight moves uh you
know maybe
maybe you can play something here or you
just continue development who knows
who knows what magnus had in mind uh but
it could be very interesting for example
bishop the e7 rook captures on e6 you
might run into this and you have no idea
what's happening
and uh well you don't want to play this
for example f captures knight captures
how the queen is under attack the
the g7 pawn will fall with check and uh
all of a sudden you're playing a game
that your opponent has had
you know at home on his board and you
know knows everything about the position
and you're stuck you know finding ideas
over the board so not something you want
to do
so instead after c4 we have bishop to e7
and now
knight to c3 okay now we're gonna defend
the pawn we have castles and now
queen to e2 uh so just continuing
development
queen to c c7 the queen already guards
the c4 pawn so it's not a problem and
now f4 magnus not
wasting time on the prophylactic king to
h1
we have knight to b6 now with a double
attack on the pawn here
attacking the bishop also so bishop back
to b3
uh and here magnus strikes in the center
with uh black strikes in the center with
e5
uh and magnus now goes knight to f5 so
for the moment
the pawns will be doubled but it's not a
problem we have captures captures
and now rook f the e8 uh and now uh what
do you play here well
magnus doesn't capture on e5 but rather
g4 and
this is uh most likely also something
that he had
at home uh you know while checking uh
some stuff out
because it really exposes the white king
a lot and unless you're really really
ready for this you do not play it in a
classical game
so here e captures on f4 now preventing
g5 with a tactic because if white goes
g5 now then d5 is very strong and you
don't have uh
well um all that much here if you
capture here just bishop c5
check and the white loses a queen so
instead after he captures an f4 we have
the simple bishop captures on f4 magnus
just continues
with a nice developing move and now
bishop to f8 also to consider maybe
queen to c6 grabbing hold of this
diagonal but we have bishop to f8
attacking carlson's queen
and the queen to g2 now the queen will
now also very nicely support this push
of the pawn
and black might play queen to c6 here
trying to trade queens but we can still
play g5 and now we could go into the
same game captures captures knight has
to move knight after d7
and even g6 is now an option so this is
something that magnus really wants to do
uh you can never capture with this spawn
because then c5 just wins the night
there's going to be a discovery from the
bishop
and it's a very very nice position for
white so after queen to g2 we have
knight captures on c4
are going for the adventurous line and
now magnus has his hands free to
start pushing those pawns so g5 we have
knight to h5
and now well you could play g6 right
away magnus starts with knights to d5
attacking the black queen
but okay the black queen will sidestep
this with check so queen to c5 check
kink to h1 and now the position is
extremely complicated
all the positions in this game will be
extremely complicated to give you an
example
uh let's say black wants to eliminate
one of the attackers let's say play
knight captures on f4
then rook captures on f4 and well your
knight here is hanging and let's say you
play b5 you want to defend it
you run into rook to g1 it's a really
really crazy move
but uh there there's no defense here
you're just getting lost for example
king to h8
we're gonna play bishop captures and
after let's say b captures rook to h4
and this is a well-known
mating setup because whatever you play
it doesn't really matter there's
no active move you can play here we're
just going to sacrifice the rook as we
would
regardless of pretty much what black
played king captures now g6 check and
after characters were
going to play queen captures king the h8
queen h5 check king to g8 and now knight
to f6
checkmate so there are ideas like these
in the position
so after king to h1 we have the
immediate b5 just adding another
defender here
uh and now comes g6 so what do you do
here the
pawn will not be captured no way you're
you're capturing the spawn to give you a
quick example for example captures
captures and captures
yes the knight here blocks the bishop
very nicely but we're just going to
shift the bishop here and
there's really no good defense against
characters and queen to h7 just bringing
the king into the game
and it broke the e6 it doesn't really
help we're going to play rook a to d1 we
can even afford such a move because
black has no active moves here
and whatever black plays let's say 95
we're still we're just going to play
bishop captures here d captures and now
bishop back to b3 and this is just
dead loss for black for example king h7
we're going to play
knight to c3 now with a double attack
here the rook is attacked this rook is
under attack
and if roo goes back to defend the other
rook and then bishop to f7 and that's it
that's uh you know very much winning for
white
so after this uh g6 idea by magnus of
course uh radic will not capture this
spawn you could
you you have to move the uh the rook
you're going to play rook to ba rook the
c
8 you're going to value rook or maybe to
a a7
in the game rook 8 the b8 was played and
now magnus plays
rook 8 to d1 uh always a useful move uh
since now you will be able to move the
queen the knight will
not hang uh because if the queen moves
queen captures on d5 comes with
checks or very unpleasant and only now
knight captures on f4 but now it's a
it's a little bit different
and while you could go g captures on f7
for example king captures and knight
captures on f4
uh it's not at all clear how to
properly continue this and uh you know
uh the clock is ticking
so magnus goes for a more
straightforward line rook captures on f4
uh remember we want to bring the rook
over to the h file to start the attack
and now comes rook to e5 radik defending
extremely well here
both players are now down to 25 minutes
on the clock uh and here
uh you have to decide uh basically
you're deciding between
queen h3 threatening not that but queen
h not that queen h3 threatening
checkmate and the rook to h4
so what do you play here the thing is
with queen h3 h6 is forced and then we
play g captures on f7 king captures and
now f6 and it's uh
very hard to imagine black surviving
such a position but
there are moves you can make for example
rook captures on d5
and not not real captures but queen to
d7 check king to g8 and now queen e6
check we win back
our piece king to h8 and now we can play
rook captures on the e5 and it's a
really really ugly position for black
but also a very complicated one so
instead magnus goes
rook to h4 right away now threatening to
well again just open up some uh lines
here on the h file
and here the most prudent defense for
black
would be queen captures on the uh sorry
uh would be
uh just to go for this uh yeah queen
captures a on f5 yeah it's
it's it's it looks like an ugly move but
you can't play it
uh the thing is uh well if rook captures
on the e5 then or just
rook the e1 check and the white has to
give the queen back so that really
doesn't
do all that much for you so instead
we're going to play queen captures here
and
now we're gonna play rook capture the
five uh we are going to play rook
captures on e5 h captures f captures and
after f captures a4
and it's uh well it's a winning position
for white um
uh it would be a miracle if black could
survive this uh
black is down the exchange he he is up
two pawns but he really does not have an
active move the bishop is really stuck
there the rook
no clear way of of what to do the
you can never capture here because the
knight hangs you can you can't move the
knight because then the rook
you know just does whatever it wants the
king is still on g8 so
it's it's a lost position for black
however
after this uh rook to h4 move we have
rook captures on
f5 and this is something that loses by
force but
the other move also loses so it kind of
doesn't matter here
radik just plays a move that's really
really complicated and he
offers magnus a way to go wrong so what
will magnus do here
uh the position is in fact completely
winning for white but as usual it's very
very complicated so feel free to pause
the video here
and win this game for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding g
captures on f7 that's not bad but it's
not the
the absolutely crushing the absolutely
crushing is the most straightforward
rook captures on h7
and the reason why this is so good is
because you don't have a
good move here for black uh to give you
a very quick example let's say black
plays
queen to f2 he wants to activate his
queen try and trade queens
it's just the fourth checkmate we
sacrifice our rook and after king
captures queen h3 check and there is
nothing to be done here you have to move
the king queen h7 is checkmate
so obviously you can't play that so
after rook captures an h7
this is no good you have to try
something uh but
what else is there to try well we could
play f captures on g6 but
then we're just gonna play queen
characters and it's still a very very
ugly position
there are of course tricks in the
position and something you have to
consider like rook to f1 check
just trying to get the rook away from
the defense of the knight here but it's
not a problem we're going to capture it
we're going to allow black to deliver
this check and now after king g1
yes black will try to check us queen d4
check we're going to play rook to f2
and now it's again not the the greatest
of positions for example rook b7 we add
another defender bishop to c2 now
and again now the threat of course is
rook to h8 check king captures and then
queen to h7 is checkmate
but there's no way to defend this any
move you play will run into this 95
again just check check
captures and queen h7 will be checkmate
so there's really no
good way to get out of this and other
than that
after rook captures on h7 uh there's
there there's the very sneaky rook
captures on the e5
but it's uh you know rook captures on d5
and now queen to e3 trying to pose some
problems here with uh with queen to e1
check while also guarding the h6 square
so white cannot really sacrifice the
rook here
but still just g captures on f7 with
check and now you can't capture the rook
because this runs into
rook to h5 the king will have nowhere to
go you're gonna have to give up the
queen
so instead king captures on f7 but now
we just start the king hunt uh
rook to f5 check and wherever the black
king goes um
you simply lose and the nicest one is
just
well if the king goes here we we can
capture on f8 with
check and then after captures we can
deliver checkmate
so uh to tell you the truth uh after
rook captures on f5
uh rook captures an h7 just you know
crushing
crushing for white g captures on f7 also
very nice but magnus tries to play
uh an even better move than the best
move recommended by the engine
and often uh when players do do this
very very strong players do
this and also some of them you know not
so strong players
uh but you you always uh you know when
you're playing you're thinking okay but
you know
the computer would probably say that
there's a there's an even greater move a
silent one you know
like a magical move and uh this is one
such move that magnus found bishop the
c2
and now everything is still in the
position as it was uh
only the bishop is now on a much nicer
square already helping out with the
attack
the problem is here magnus probably
missed one move that
radic has and that's the one that didn't
work
if rook was on h7 and that is queen to
f2
and now if the rook was on h7 you
remember that just sacrificing the rook
on h8 and bringing the queen here would
be checkmate
but now there is no such idea so now
magnus has to go for g
captures an f7 check king captures and
now
uh bishop captures an f5 you don't have
to capture the rook right away there's
also the the very sneaky queen to e4
idea
because now after black trades queens
for example captures captures you can
trap the rook with king to g2 so you can
always
also win the rook like that and maybe it
gives you in
a little bit of a better position maybe
a more active one but magnus grabs the
rook right away
uh they are already very very low on
time and
uh well they still have like 15 moves to
go before time control so here
queen captures an h4 and now comes to
rook to f1 now threatening some nasty
discoveries magnets down already to two
minutes on the clock and radic or some
17 and a half minutes i think on the
clock
now threatening some very nasty
discoveries but the king just sidesteps
uh
with king to g8 and now it's a problem
what do you play here well
magnus continues with rook to f4 it's
the best move but it also allows black
to just
uh you know run into uh for whites to go
for black to go into queen to e1 check
and now you will
have a very simple perpetual one other
thing you could do is queen to
h6 but it's still uh just a more
complicated um
uh you know wait uh way to draw the game
because now after queen to f2
you can play g5 attack the rook here but
now
bishop captures an h7 king captures and
rook to f6 now
and once you move the queen queen to h3
we're going to play rook to f7
check bishop to g7 and now rook captures
on g7 with check and now after king
captures you're going to have a
perpetual here with white
uh queen to f6 check king h7 queen to f7
check king h8 and now we're just gonna
repeat
this uh for forever so uh that did not
happen like i said after rook to f4
uh voit decided that uh he will continue
this game we have queen to e1 check
rook to f1 and now uh not going back
queen to h4
if queen to h4 then magnus probably
repeats rook to f4 but that also means
that uh well
although you tied a classical game you
have to play magnus now in
in a rapid match which is well much much
worse some would say
so here queen to e5 radik wants to
continue the game
and now magnus has to find uh well a
playable move he is very low on the
clock
he has some two minutes on the clock
radix some 10 minutes and here he plays
queen to h3 he offers the knight with
check which is extremely interesting but
there was also the very interesting rook
to f3
maybe something to uh you know just
improve the position a little bit
and uh but it's still it's still not you
know just offers a chance for for black
to blunder because now
black can just go queen to e1 check
we're gonna have to block with rook to
f1
the thing is only if queen captures on
d5 then you have this
very very sneaky bishop captures on h7
with check
and now you can't capture it because
well rook to h3 check and black loses
the queen
so king to h8 but now bishop to d3
preventing black from from reaching the
back rank well also now the bishop here
is a very strong attacker
so queen to e6 we're gonna play rook to
h3 with
czech king g8 and now bishop the e for
threatening to win the queen
so knight to b6 guarding the d5 square
and now bishop h7 check king f7
and queen to f2 with check we have queen
f6 and now for example rook f2
and now white uh you know maybe maybe
get something out of this but it's a
very tricky line and of course radek um
he's he's shown uh he will not fall for
such ideas so magnus goes for the
immediate queen to h3
he offers the knight on d5 with check
and radik really spent a lot of time
here calculating what to do
because uh well he he either finds a win
or he grabs the draw
uh but uh grabbing the draw also means
that he will have to face magnus in
uh uh rapid tie breaks uh and in the end
he played queen captures on d5 with
check there was also maybe the
possibility of just playing h6 and then
you know what happens
uh but it's a very very wild position
you know completely unexplored territory
now with such
so little time on the clock so instead
after queen the h3 he played queen
capture sunday if i went to
rook to f3 and now queen to d1 with
check now we have rook to f1 by magnus
you can't play queen to f1 you're down
material black will more than
more than happily trade here let's say
knight captures on v2 and i mean black
is up
up a piece and you know up three pawns
so magnus has to block with the rook
rook f1 still keeping an eye on the
queen here and also threatening just uh
you know win the game uh but now queen
to d5
check rook to f3 if you go king to g1
again there's
simply queen to c5 check king h1 and now
g6 and
you you can't uh prolong the game black
simply has too much material
so rook to f3 again going for this h7
pawn and now queen to d1
check and it was in this position on
move 34 that magnus and
vitasha agreed to a draw yet again as
there uh
well seems to be nothing more than that
that can be done here
uh so really really uh a wild one uh
yesterday you know anything could have
happened today anything could have
happened but
really that one chance that magnus had
of playing rook captures on h7 i think
that's what happened here
uh rook caltrans and h7 something anyone
plays even capturing with a pawn is
something that that you might consider
but i think he played bishop to c2
trying to play that one move that kind
of
you know just improves everything like
it's like playing a move that's even
better than the best move
uh but then you miss a simple idea like
queen to f2
which you probably saw in your
calculations only you saw that you know
if if rook captures here then this is
impossible
and you thought that maybe it's
impossible even if the rook does not
capture on h7
it happens you know things like that
happen in chess
but yeah like i said after this queen to
d1 check players agree to a draw and
that's it
they will now go into rapid tie breaks
and we'll see what happens there
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it keep using hashtag suggestion
if you have any of your own favorite
games i will of course check it out and
then see
if it's an interesting one for everyone
to enjoy
uh so hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank richard campbell robert
walker on
um anshuranjan uh harry walk and johan
bridger for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day